i'm going to start the meeting so
welcome everybody
to uh our uh
systems and model synthesis workshop
simon's institute
workshop today we are going to focus on
the synthesis of
cyber physical systems and we have uh
today very very famous and uh
very good speakers and i'm going to
start with the
first one karine belta who is a
professor
in the department of mechanical
engineering at boston university
where he holds the the gun family
distinguished
faculty fellowship he's also the
director of the boston university lab
and of the center for autonomous uh and
robotic systems
uh short cars and is also affiliated
with the department of electrical and
computer engineering and the
department and the division of systems
engineering at boston university
his research focuses on dynamics and
control theory with a particular
emphasis on hybrid and cyber physical
systems
formal synthesis and verification and
robotics
notable include
sf career award 2008 for sr young
investigator
and 2000 the ieee tcns outstanding
paperwork he's an
ieee fellow and a distinguished lecturer
of the ieee controller systems society
kalinda floor is yours thank you radha
so let me screen
can you guys see my powerpoint thing yes
yes
i always have visuals going to
presentation mode but uh let me give it
a try
how is this guys can you actually yeah
that's it
oh perfect okay all right all right good
morning everybody and uh again
thanks a lot for the uh for the
invitation i'm gonna i'm gonna talk
about an
optimization based approach to uh
synthesis of control strategies for
dynamical systems with the emphasis on
on safety and uh the work that i'm gonna
show was mostly done by
uh can you guys see my mouse too yep
yeah
by this guy his name is way shower um
he's my
student at boston university but this
work was actually done while he wasn't
emotional and internal emotional where i
also have an affiliation
so i'm not sure how much you know
emotional but it's this company is
exactly one year old yesterday
so it was uh it has its roots in
autonomy and active
and then it was uh was formed as a uh
joint venture between active and hyundai
so now it's
kind of like all over the globe and they
do autonomous cars
okay so no surprise that
the motivation for the work that i'm
going to show today comes from
autonomous driving
which is an important but challenging
problem um we have to deal with
realistic vehicle dynamics which can be
high dimensional and highly non-linear
most of the time this problem is posed
as a optimal control problem where we
have to optimize the cost such as energy
distance traveled deviation from a
reference trajectory the environments
can be quite complex and can be changing
can be partially known
autonomous cars have local limited
sensing which can also be noisy
and um last but not least and actually
with particular relevance to this stock
we need to satisfy rules and these rules
can be
literally traffic laws such as
stop at the traffic light stay in lane
keep clearance from parked cars from
pedestrians
satisfy the speed limit but can also be
comfort
requirements such as you know some sort
of a notion of
keep jerk low and obviously they come
with priorities
obviously you want to pay more attention
to
keeping clearance from pedestrians than
satisfying the speed limit
so satisfying rules involve some sort of
a global notion of
minimum violation also because most of
the time they're in conflict with each
other there is
especially in heavy traffic there's no
way you can satisfy all the rules
here's an example then i'm gonna um
come back i'm actually showing kind of
the solution at the beginning and then
i'm gonna come back
to the at the end of the talk and i'm
gonna revisit this example after i show
some of the technical approach behind it
so the dynamics that i'm showing in here
which i'm not gonna go through details
is this is
um seven-dimensional and it's actually
defines defined along
a reference trajectory so what i want to
notice is that it's high dimension and
it's non-linear
uh we need to solve an optimal control
problem the trajectory tracking that we
do in this case let me run this movie so
while i do this um
i'm not sure where you can still see
these labels there
the uh trajectory tracking that we do in
this case is um
stay as close as possible to the middle
of the current lane
there are state limitations such as
steering angle vehicle speed
there are tight control bounds and we
want to
achieve some sort of a global
satisfaction of a
prioritized set of rules and the set of
rules that we have here
cannot see them i'm showing here at the
top
the uh abbreviation stance was torque
stands for
total order over equivalence relations
so what i'm showing in here is a
set of eight rules priorities go from
bottom to top so the top will have the
highest priority rules and whatever i'm
showing in
this rectangles these are rules of the
of equivalent priority
okay so one of the requirements that uh
we need to satisfy here is safety
you can uh look at this set of rules
most of them are clearance type rules
which means that we need to make sure
that while we drive around we keep a
certain distance
between the ego and the other traffic
participants
and that formally translates to the
notion of safety and
what i'm showing here is the so-called
cbf approach
control barrier function approach and
actually paul is one of the authors on
this paper which
introduced this um you're an author to
this right
okay always still there but so uh
they focused on a non-linear system with
a certain structure called the alpha and
control systems where there is a drift
and then the control enters
are finally along the control directions
in this matrix g
there are control bounds and the goal
here is to make a set a forwarding
variant and this set is described using
a differential function b
and the sufficient condition for this to
happen is to satisfy this
equality inequality story so if you can
find u
satisfying this for all x and c and for
all you and u
then you can guarantee that if you start
in c you stay in c so that's a notion of
like for example if you start if you
start far away from the pedestrian
you're going to stay far away from the
pedestrian
and one thing that i wanted to notice in
here is that this uh what you have on
the right hand side of this inequality
is an offering function in u if i if i
fix
x this is actually a fine function u
and another thing we have to deal with
and the problem that i showed is to
actually go to specific states
like for example if you have a reference
transaction which is given as a sequence
of points then you have to go and visit
every point
if you have a goal where you want to go
then again you have to make sure you
converge there
and the approach that i'm proposing here
which is again
proposed by the same authors is to use
control japan functions
so sata same type of control system
control bounds
um a scalar function which satisfies
these two equations is called a control
japan function
and if we find the clf which such that
for all u
this inequality is satisfied then we are
guaranteed that we have exponential
stabilization to the origin
and again i want you to notice in here
that uh this inequality again
is a alfine function in u in the sense
that if i kept x constant then this is
alpha and
nu which is the same applies to the
dynamics of the system
so then you see through these two
ingredients i can formulate the
optimal control problem for this type of
dynamics obviously control bounds
i i assume here a quadratic cost and
um we want to be safe and we're going to
impose safety with the cbf
for the variance of this set and
convergence to a desired state with the
clfv and formally this translates to an
optimization problem which looks like
this
so you should also if kalin so if you
wouldn't have uh
the constraints it would be just solving
the riccati equation
in every time step uh if this was linear
yeah yeah i mean it is linear when you
when you fix x yeah so it's fine yeah
but i'm going to fix
x here and i'm going to get also
something that's all
that's simple but you know my point was
that if you just don't do anything and
look at this optimization problem it's
hard because
yeah yeah trains are ugly but
again what was proposed by these people
who i don't know who these people are
but what they did
they proposed to um to take the time
interval that you're interested in zero
to t
cut it into small pieces and then solve
an optimization problem in each of these
intervals
so for example in here at the beginning
of an interval um you have a certain
value for the state x
then uh you you plug in that value in
this constraints so
x is now constant and known these are
linear inequalities in u quadratic cost
let's assume you use polyhedral this
becomes a qp so you can solve this qp
really quickly and really fast
find the control applied and keep it
constant during all this time interval
integrate forward in time find the next
state and so on
right so this approach obviously is uh
computationally efficient qps can be
solved very fast
obviously you play the price here you
become sub-optimal
also convergence might not be guaranteed
but
if you cut this very very finely you
might hope that actually everything is
everything is going to be fine
okay so in my group were when we started
looking into this
um this approach basically i'm gonna
we started from the observation that in
the original
um work um the sufficient conditions
only work for relative degree one
so by relative degree here i mean
exactly relative degree the way it's
defined in nonlinear control theory it's
like an output function function of the
state
if you differentiate it once you don't
see the state means that
it's relatively it's high relative
degree and then you keep on
differentiated and
at some point you're going to see the
input basically more or less the same
happens here because you have these
derivatives and i want to show that even
for a very simple
control problem which is an adaptive
cruise control problem
and very simple dynamics which is a
double integrator in here
the original cbf approach would not work
because uh
when you write down the cbf uh
um condition which is this one
you won't see the control because it
vanishes and again those of you familiar
with um
input organization would recognize that
actually it's you know it's like a
well-known issue and then so this is one
thing and another thing which is
actually the most important and there
are people spend time on
studying this is the feasibility of the
resulting qps
right so think of um a car
moving in a uh moving in heavy traffic
there will be a lot of safety
constraints coming from other cars
coming from pedestrians coming from
staying in lane
you would have to satisfy many
constraints like this and if you have
tight control bounds it's very likely
the optimization problem will become
infeasible the constraints that would be
empty
and that's particularly uh the case
because of the
myopic approach that we have in here so
we cut this uh
time into very small uh pieces and then
again we solve an optimization problem
here then we apply the control by the
time we get here plug in the state that
we got
after forward integration in time into
this equations
you might get very close to an obstacle
one of the um
constraints might become active and you
become invisible and you're basically
stuck there's nothing you can do
so again just very briefly i'm going to
give you a uh i'm going to
a very high level overview of our
approach to deal with these two
limitations first of all
to deal with the hype the relative
degree problem we proposed
high order control barrier functions
so very briefly rather than just having
one constraint one function we actually
have
m of them where m is the relative degree
of the of the constraint
each of them induces a set in the same
way that
the original constraint induced a set
and then the main theorem here is that
if we
satisfy a uh inequality which
looks uh just slightly more general than
the one that you saw before
then you can guarantee that the
intersection of these sets is forward
invariant
and in particular c1 with some
conservatives
here c1 is also a forward invariant and
this is what you wanted to achieve
on the feasibility issue uh i'm gonna
show two main ideas and the first idea
with two different flavors
so um one way to deal with visibility
that we proposed was to actually add
more constraints
which is kind of counter-intuitive
because we're invisible because we have
too many constraints
but somehow it makes sense to add more
constraints to make the problem feasible
and these constraints that we add we
call them feasibility constraints
so i think maybe this picture would help
a little bit clarify this
counterintuitive approach so what i
showed before in the traditional
approach at some at some time you solve
an optimization problem you find the
control you keep it constant
you integrate forward in time you end up
somewhere
my mouse is kind of can you guys see my
mouse moving still yes yes okay
you might end up in the state in this
state you might uh you might be
infeasible
versus let's say that somehow you can
characterize this
conflict situations and you can
characterize them in such a way that you
can come up with closed form
closed form differentiable expressions
of
of conditions which would ensure that
this would not happen
and then this constraint you would
enforce it using
get an extra cbf so basically make sure
that during widely evolved during the
dynamics of the system
this constraint is set so basically i
think
so the the constraint would be this
function right so other than just going
here because i know something bad will
happen i would actually go here
again i don't have many details but
there's uh if you're interested i can
provide the
the technical technical description of
this but
as i already said the um the steps for
this approach would be first to
find conflicts between constraints and
then formulate constraints
to avoid such conflicts and then find
some sufficient condition that would
inflate
enforce some such constraints and then
write and then enforce the satisfaction
of the sufficient conditions using cbf
and basically when you solve your
optimization problem in addition to what
you had before actually by the way i'm
showing here this for relative degree
one because it's simpler to write but we
have a version that works for relative
degree
um m so in addition to your original
safety constraints
you're also going to have something like
this where this function has an
expression and there is a theorem that
we have on how to construct this
and depends both on the original
constraint
conditional constraint b and the control
bounds that you have
another approach to adding feasibility
constraints was to actually learn them
which is uh quite intuitive so
and also it shows to work for um it has
some sort of a nice symmetry properties
in the sense that if i can
if we can construct this for an obstacle
of a certain geometry we only tried
spheres because that's the easiest case
but
if i constrain constraints for a sphere
and move the sphere around you can
actually automatically generate
constraints for spheres placed anywhere
let me let me write this movie right the
movie so i can actually see how it works
but the main idea is that you know once
you have an obstacle of a certain
geometry you start sampling
very very densely around the obstacle
and literally at
every point solve the cb fclf problem
and see if it's feasible or not
and if it's visible you label it with
feasible if it's unfeasible you label it
as unfusible
and then and then learn a classifier
that nicely separates the feasible from
unfeasible
and then uh if you're careful you can
construct this classifier such
that is differentiable and then you you
impose the satisfaction of the
classifier using
yet an extra cpf that you add to your
optimization problem
and again you cannot prove much in here
because again you have some learning in
here but in practice it seems to
work quite nicely in pretty cluttered
environment
and with local sensing and you see here
i'm all basically when you solve this
optimization problem
in this learning problem sorry you solve
it once but then you can easily
translate it everywhere as long as you
stick to the geometry
that you had initially
and the second approach that we had for
feasibility was to use something called
adaptive cbf
which you called adder cbf and that's
actually kind of tightly related to our
definition of
higher order control barrier function
remember these are the functions that we
have which are different from the ones
that are
that i showed you before in the sense
that now rather than just having these
class k functions here we also have some
penalties
which are uh functions of time
so that hence the name adaptive
so long story short what you want to do
we want to uh
define oxidative dynamics control
systems
for each penalties and use the controls
in this auxiliary dynamics to relax the
constraints that we have in the original
control view from the original problem
so we need to make sure that this whole
product stays the class k function so we
need to guarantee that
these pis that we have here are positive
and then we enforce this using again
the cbf approach applied to this system
we don't have a clear understanding on
how to construct this but what we did so
far we just chose linear functions and
it seems to work quite nicely
obviously they can be maybe extended and
done
better and the crm
that ensures for the variance for c1
looks a little bit more complicated like
this but
what you can see in here there is a
relaxation
because we have this extra control
variables and then i'm not showing the
cost in here but
obviously in the cost we'll have
actually we relax this one too
and this relaxation variable goes as a
slack variable in the cost
again given the short time i'm not going
to show any any details but there is a
paper which actually will appear in
transactions very soon so you can
i can refer you to that
okay so here's uh back to our original
problem
i want to solve an optimal control
problem obviously with the quadratic
cost because i'm going to use the method
that i showed you before
subject to complicated dynamics
the trajectory tracking that we're going
to do here would be a following the
middle of the current lane
the state limitation our steering angle
vehicle speed
the control bounds are jerk steering
acceleration
and we want to achieve minimum violation
of a prioritized set of rules so just a
few words on a few more words on this
so our approach to satisfying rules was
inspired by
uh some earlier work by andreas sensei
and also
you guys might know him he like i think
he was a postdoc with emilio and eth
um so they uh they defined this rulebook
as a set of rules
uh which are prioritized and for which
you can quantify satisfaction
right so if you think of if you look at
this example here so there is the ego
and it has there are four rules
one rules is to stay in lane no
collision
satisfy speed limit and don't accelerate
too much
and so this violation score basically
means that once you have a trajectory
and a rule rather than just having
boolean satisfaction meaning that the
trajectory satisfies the rule or not you
want to be you want to quantify uh the
degree of satisfaction
those of you familiar with stl this is
literally
actually it is that in some approaches
that we have another people did
but um and what we have here is just
maybe
it's actually a particular case of stl
formulas
and robustness so the robustness would
give you the
uh degree of violation so this is just
one sided robustness we
this in this at least in this work we
don't um we don't reward
um good satisfaction we just penalize
bad violation
so once you have this um like for
example in here
you can try to say what i'm doing on
time
um we wanna we wanna use the rulebook to
do trajectory comparison
and hopefully rank trajectories and
here's a
simple example i have three trajectories
abc
which one is the best with respect to
this priority structure
in this project structure again remember
we have um
priorities going up from bottom to top
and the
equivalent rules are showing in
rectangles so what i'm showing here with
the color coding
um so this is our one no collision i'm
showing the violation scores for the red
the green and the blue trajectory so
a obviously is uh so a
violates um collision because it gets
too close in here
the other ones do not and so on
and then when i compare trajectories i
want to say that uh a transaction is
better than another if it only violates
low priority rules
right very intuitive and if it happens
that they violate
rules of the same priority then i have
to look a little bit deeper i have to
look at the violation scores and
obviously i'm going to pick the one with
the least violation score
in this particular example again a would
definitely be the worst because it has
some violation here
for the highest priority rule
and then in between b and c apparently
they both violate rules
which are equivalent which have the same
priorities so i have to look a little
bit deeper and apparently
b does better in terms of violating
[Music]
r2 so we choose b actually just realize
now that actually it violates
blue a little bit more and some does not
but my example might not be very
but i think you've got the point i just
have to fix this example
okay so now uh but i already showed you
the dynamics that we used
so i'm not going to go through details
in here but this uh the details are
given in this
uh in this paper um this
dynamics are defined along a
reference trajectory which is actually
good for us because we want to do
trajectory tracking regardless
and also in this particular case our
tracking problem just comes to making
two of the state's variables converge to
desired values
so we can easily do a trajectory
tracking using uh
clf and you can see here that the setup
that i'm showing here is slightly
different than the one that i showed
before which
was a zero here which basically means
that we're going to relax
convergence we're going to relax
trajectory tracking and in general
convergence to some state which
is i think it's a common technique and
uh cbfclf approach
we always think of convergence as being
a soft constraint versus
safety being a heart constraint so you
don't want to relax the barrier
functions but you want to relax the
control diagonal functions
and another ingredient that we're using
here which again hiding under the carpet
is that
most of the rules that we have involve
clearance
and usually we put boxes around
the uh radon running out of time right
yeah kind of i mean uh okay i'm the one
to have questions you know
yeah okay so basically what we do here
we also find a way to
express clearance rules using
differentiable functions
by over approximating them and this is
the big optimization problem and what we
do here
really we have an iterative way of
relaxing rules so first of all we try to
find a trajectory that satisfies all the
rules
if we cannot we start relaxing rules of
lower priority and hopefully at some
point end up with a solution
and here's an example of such an optimal
problem optimal control problem where
basically
find a we cannot find a trajectory that
satisfies everything so we have to
compromise and violate r5
and one last point that i want to make
is that uh this
method can also be uh transformed into a
pass fail criterion where you're giving
a
candidate trajectory and you see how bad
it does in terms of violating these
rules
and if you're using your optimal control
approach you can find one which
does better in the sense that i defined
before then you can pass or fail this
trajectory
and that's it and again this is way he
did most of the work and these are my
collaborators emotional
who are part of this and also ways
co-advised by chris cassandra's
thank you very much very very nice talk
so
do we have questions from the audience
if not i'm going to take advantage of
this so i have a couple of questions so
so this control barrier function i mean
the cbf and clfs
are they fully determined once you give
the
dynamics or there is something to learn
there
in the traditional approach they're
given you actually have to pick up those
class k functions and then but
you know i mean what we do and actually
there is another approach that we had
which i'm not showing here
you can actually parameterize those uh
those
um class key functions by having them as
power functions so you can use the
powers
to increase the stability but also in
the other cbf that i'm showing here you
see that we're actually
messing up with this um the barrier
functions by introducing
time varying penalties
so actually in fact you could in fact
you could write down this
you know you could use machine learning
actually to write down this
parameterized uh
clf and cbs and you know learn only what
is
you know a parameter there yeah yeah yes
yeah and we have some primary results on
that and actually other people do that
too i know aaron has some
results on that i think it's anything
called shield a little bit of that too
yeah so yeah
definitely you can use machine learning
for that and would it help if you would
make also f x uh linear i mean like g of
x
times x plus making this linear
yeah i mean you you can transform i
think you can always transform through a
translation f of x if it has a zero you
can make it like
g of x times x now let's say h of x
times x
yeah yeah yeah of course i mean you know
the main point is that you want to be
able to write down these types of
conditions that's why you need that
alpha and structure but once you have
the alpha structure and you can write
this you kind of more or less sit in
here but obviously
if you're the linear you're going to
have better complexity
but again the alpha form is necessary so
you can write those so you can take the
lead derivatives and see how the value
of the barrier function
changes along the trajectories yeah yeah
sorry how did i i mean i i was always
wondering how how is the
control community i mean the control
community came up with this
form uh this kind of linear
linear uh
state dependent coefficients do they
come up with
they try to say this is kind of like
like linear and now i have
state dependent made and uh but well i
think you know
this is what i know from linear system
yeah it kind of feels weird i mean paulo
what did you take over i think this
question is more for you
um yeah so it has been shown
that even if the dynamics that is the
right-hand side of the differential
equation is completely non-linear
in x and u there is a simple trick
you can do to always recover this form
and this simple trick is to say that
rather than choosing you
we're going to choose the derivative of
you it's like adding an integrator
and by doing that simple trick you
always recover this form
so with no loss of generality one can
assume that
the system should be of this form but
there are many
but most systems are directly of this
form so from basic
physics g would be a force
acting there and we can change the
magnitude of the force so the u
is as changing the magnitudes and g
dictates the direction in which the
force is pushing
and an f is a drift that you don't have
any control over and have somehow
fight it with the control directions
that you have in the gym
yeah very nice very nice all right thank
you
yeah go ahead no no no no no go ahead go
ahead
no not but you know you want to cut
now what i'm saying is that you know
it's most mechanical systems
actually have this form so it's not a
restrictive uh yeah
it's interesting because my my modeling
and it's kind of like a
mechanic system so if you modern neurons
with uh
as capacitors you end up exactly with
this form you know that's kind of
interesting for me
uh you know so
that's why i got interested in this form
that you guys
i i still have to find out to to use
that form you know uh
to take advantage more of it all right
so
colleen here is your applause thank you
very much for your very
you nice talk to stop sharing stop
shooting out